hi I'm Gareth Edwards and today I'm
going to break down a scene from The
Creator they've come for me I have to
help there's nothing we can do I have to
help Alfie we got to
go Alie
Alie help F this scene is actually a
great example of rolling with your
punches and how sometimes you can turn a
negative into a positive I wanted to
shoot this whole sequence in Cambodia at
a floating village and what happened is
the pandemic came along and they were
like we can go to Cambodia but you can't
shoot the whole sequence there you're
going to have to do all the big
explosion stuff in Thailand and so I was
like okay we got to find a place that
looks incredible and we looked
everywhere and just by she I say Shear
flute but location Scouts found this
bridge this kind of I think it's the
second biggest
wooden Trestle bridge in the world or
something that you can walk across
anyway it's massive and um and it looked
like something straight out a David lean
movie and I and now looking back on it
there's this whole sequence that takes
place with this bridge and it feels like
embarrassing that I hadn't written it
that way or storyboarded it that way
that this was just uh an accident of the
pandemic like forcing me not to film
where I wanted to film so that was that
was massive industrial like magic were
really good in that a lot of the people
you see in the sequence uh that are
robots or AI they weren't wearing those
special suits they didn't have the
motion capture suits on um I didn't want
anybody to look like a robot or have to
be a robot in the sequence we just
filmed it with a everyone as a human and
then in post production once it was
edited when we were like then we watched
it together and said okay it'd be really
cool if this woman was a robot if that
that person running past there your eye
goes to to them so let's make them a
robot so like we weren't stuck with
anyone having to be Ai and and so like
in terms of the design like if you look
at Alfie essentially Alfie is I mean
like what we did is we we drew a little
bit of a Terminator
skull and and robotic skull I guess
Ralph mcquarry and there's so many
influences Chris Cunningham everybody is
in there but basically created a
metallic kind of skull and and neck
and then put the active skin on top and
then with James Klein we did a million
different um designs of like how to
remove the skin in such a way that you
still had empathy for the character and
one of the things we noticed was that if
you cut the neck off if you remove the
throat it felt like a floating head or a
mask and it you it's there was something
uncanny about it that you kind of reject
or it doesn't feel quite as human so we
left the throat in and then basically
you're following the circle of you once
you remove the ears I want wanted I
wanted it to be that whatever we did it
didn't look like Prosthetics it l there
was no way this could have been makeup
and so the clearest way to do that is
punch a hole through you know create
negative space in the head and so we you
know you know look at the ear so if we
remove the ear you get this circular
shape and there's so many designs with
robots that have circles around here and
so it was like let's just punch a circle
right through the skull and and then you
just like you kept like trying to remove
and add skin until it just felt right it
was it was the very last thing we
finished designing before ilm kind of
pulled it out of our fingers because if
we didn't get Alfie looking right like
that was she was going to achieve high
score with the amount of eyeballs on her
in the movie so it was like we got to
get this
right
we had we need a lot of smoke in this
sequence and uh Jonathan who was our
special effect supervisor um I was like
we're going to have to take the biggest
smoke machine you have to Thailand and
he um he lovingly referred to the one he
did eventually ship over as the giant
mother and so we had the giant mother on
a car you can only transport it on a on
a truck it was so big and then on this
particular day we're in like a floating
village so they had to then put the
truck on a boat and then they had to
gamble every morning on which direction
the wind was going to blow because it
would take hours to get it off the boat
get the boat the other side of the
bridge get it back on like you'd ruin
the whole day so so Jonathan every day
had to watch like a hawk how the wind
was changing and get the boat the right
side of the um right side of the bridge
so the smoke would drift into shot and
not out and it was it's very easy to
just take this stuff for granted but the
guys did a phenomenal Al job I think
layering up all the depth in this
sequence so that it had this real
cinematic feel to it the thing I'm most
proud of in this you know in the movie
and especially you can see in this
sequence is that mixture of the what
Star Wars does so well is like the
distant past and the distant future I
love the idea of like a Timeless like
there's nothing contemporary in this
sequence everything's like something
that you could have seen 30 50 years ago
in terms of you know even 100 years ago
in ter terms of the floating village
aspect of it all and then mixed with
these giant like Manga style tanks we
James Klein who designed the tanks um
our goal was to have them look like a a
model kit you could buy from Bandai like
some sort of thing that would have been
in a manga film and so what we kept
doing as stupid as it sounds is when we
did a design we would take that design
and we'd put it on a Bandai model box
and just see if we got jealous like we
weren't going to stop until we went I
really want that model on my desk and so
so there's like negative space there's
all kinds of interesting
things we tried lots of different
approaches of Designing the robots um at
one point you know we we got insect
heads so the heads of insects um from
things like um praying mantis or
whatever and then we pretended that
someone who designed the Sony Walkman
had to make this insect head and so it's
kind of like half organic half product
design and then we took things like
you'll see some of these robots um we
took film like home Cinema projectors
and and used that as a head and then
started to try and make it feel more
like asymmetrical and and characterful
and and there's a really fine line
between it becoming like a kids movie
where it's too cartoony or not having
any personality at all and so it was
really difficult knif Edge to just get
them looking cool and like there was a
there was someone inside a soul but it
wasn't like like a kitty film we had
these new cameras that were um
incredibly lightweight and also very
sensitive to light so you didn't need
all these major massive lights you
normally have on a on a film set
sometimes and so it meant we could be
very Run and Gun and we had a 360 Dee
view like it was always really important
to me that the crew and there was for
some of these big set pieces with the
giant
explosions um we needed a lot of crew to
help us pull this off but they all had
to stay hidden and so and anyone in shot
had to wear a um costumes as if they
were locals and stuff and so basically
everyone's hiding around the corner in
every single scene they're either inside
a Hut or behind one and you can't so the
camera can always look in any direction
so we can have that sort of chaotic War
feeling and I and and like depending on
how some random moment that happens with
explosions or gunfire I can quickly
change the
[Music]
composition so there's a monkey in this
so basically like this monkey is a
phenomenal right I think was one of the
best actors
in the movie and and I'll let you into a
little secret but I was like they showed
us a video of how this monkey rehearsing
and it was brilliant I couldn't figure
out how they'd let you know got the
monkey to do all this stuff and um then
we came to set and I got you know got
the camera monkey comes on and I start
noticing the corner of my eye there's
like another monkey over there and the
monkey that's in the movie is a female
monkey and as soon as it did a good take
its reward was to go over to the male
monkey and let's just say have a cuddle
right it was a little bit more than a
cuddle um but everyone was like what's
going on and then suddenly it would
finish and come back and do another take
and it was like every time it did a good
take it went over to the maale monkey
and got a cuddle and it was like okay
this is an interesting way to uh get a
performance